okay hi welcome back everyone thank you
for joining us
for today's presentation entitled
spatial mapping of gene expression
in tumors using the rns rna scope
technology
and it's my real pleasure to introduce
you to anushka dixit
scientist from advanced cellular
diagnostics
and for her complete biography and all
our speakers you can visit the tab at
the bottom of your screen
for more information now if you have any
questions during
this presentation we encourage you to
submit them in the q
a box and our speaker will respond back
to you
via email so please join me in welcoming
anushka i'll turn the presentation over
to her
thank you for being here today uh today
i'll be talking to you about
the rna scope technology which is a gene
expression technology that allows you
to visualize your targets uh with
spatial and morphological resolution
for those of you who are not familiar
with the rna scope technology
it is an in-situ hybridization platform
that was specially designed to overcome
some of the traditional limitations
of the ish assay while still maintaining
high sensitivity
and specificity of detection
the rna scope assay is perfectly
designed
to perform gene expression analysis with
spatial resolution
in very complex and heterogeneous
tissues like the tumor
where you have different cell types
interacting with each other
sorry my slide just went
on its own without me
that's okay huh i wonder what happened
um cindy you didn't touch it right
[Music]
sorry
that's okay um you anushka you can start
from the top of slide three was that the
one that you were on
i was in side three yes so can i start
from that okay
yes yeah definitely let me make a note
really quick give me just a second
sure okay so yeah
i think i added four laps how do i do
that
oh no okay
okay all right
so give it just a few seconds and then
you can begin
the iron scope technology is perfectly
positioned
to visualize street expression analysis
with spatial resolution
in really complex tissues like the tumor
a heterogeneous tissue like the tumor
has different cell types
that are interacting with each other
within the tumor micro environment
so to study the function of the
different cell types present within the
tuber micro environment
it is essential to use a highly
sensitive technology
the three major parts of the artery
scope technology
are the target probe design where acd
will design
a specific target flow against the mrna
transcript of your interest
the signal amplification strategy which
includes
a proprietary amplification system
which allows very high signaturized
ratio
and a detection and quantification
system which
allows visualization of a single
molecule of rna
at single cell resolution so this assay
can be applied to
a wide variety of target types which
include
mrnas non-coding rnas splice variants
homologous sequences short targets point
mutations
and so on additionally our assay is
flexible and can be made applicable
to ffbe tissues fresh and fixed frozen
tissues
cultured cells and pbmcs
next i want to talk to you about uh the
two key features of our technology
which are the probe design and the
signal amplification system
as you can see on the screen our probe
is depicted as a single z molecule
to mainly highlight the different
regions of the probe
the target binding region of the probe
which is the bottom part of the z
uh points onto your target transcript of
interest
the preamplifier binding site which is
the top part of the z
is where your amplification tree will
form and the linker region
connects these two parts of the probe
now we design our probes such that two z
probes
bind in tandem onto your target sequence
next to each other
once they are bound you have a
pre-amplifier
bind on top of the z-pair which is
followed by
binding of amplifier and labeled probes
now these can either be chromogenically
or fluorescently labeled
verbs so this amplification strategy
allows for very high sensitivity of
detection and
detects low expressing targets as well
now how do we ensure high specificity as
i mentioned earlier
the two z molecules need to the two z
probes
have to bind in tandem next to each
other
if a z probe does not bind specifically
to the target sequence
then the preamplifier cannot bind onto
the zebra
and there won't be any signal detected
as a result
this allows for high signature noise
ratio ensuring
high sensitivity and specificity of
detection
in addition to our rna scope assays we
also have
the base copaces which are specifically
designed
to visualize short targets such as exon
junctions
highly moderate sequences and point
locations
for our early scope essays we designed
probes
as a pair of 20 zz probes
which is a pooled pair of groups and
this is again
really for targets that are over 300
nucleotides in length
whereas our base scope assays are
designed for short targets
and therefore have one two three zzz uh
pair of probes and this is mainly for
targets that are between 50
to 300 nucleotides long
in this slide uh i have described the
breadth
of our assay portfolio uh which gives
you a sense of
how flexible we are when it comes to
flexing and
sample times you can either perform
singleplex analysis
or duplex or up to 12 flex for target
detection
so for 12 threads you can visualize 12
targets simultaneously
on your sample of interest now the 12
flex assay
is applicable for fresh and fixed rows
and tissues
our assays can also be performed both
with manual
or automated platforms and currently we
have over 25 000 catalog probes
that are available to use in addition we
can also custom design
any probe you want as long as we know
the target sequence of
interest in the next part of my
presentation
i will talk about uh the rna scope um
workflow in combination with the geomex
tsp
and during that part of my presentation
i will focus
on the rn scope multiplex v2 assay
but for now let's look at some of the
applications of the underscore
technology
as i mentioned we have been widely
applied for detection of
long-run coding rna splice variants cdr3
sequences
gpcrs and so on and because our
flexibility of application
we have been used for basic science
research
in neuroscience stem cell and
developmental biology
we have also been used for infectious
disease research to identify
nucleic acids of emerging pathogens and
study
infection-induced inflammation
then it can also use in biopharma
discovery and development
to assess the pre-clinical safety and
specificity
of certain cell and gene therapies and
finally
we have been used in cancer and clinical
research
for the purpose of today's presentation
i'll be focusing on
the applications of rna scope in tumor
biology
and immune oncology
rna scope has been widely used to study
different aspects of cancer research
on the screen are listed a few
applications of
rna scope in oncology rna scope can be
used to visualize tumor neutrogena
to characterize immune cells and soluble
factors
to visualize specific cdr3 regions on
tcrs
then to detect splice variants of
certain targets
implicated in cancer identify non-coding
ironings
important in cancer progression
spatially
map and validate single cell hourly
sequencing data
when it as it relates to cancer and
detect
engineered immune cells within animal
models
let's start with an example of how rna
scope can be used
to visualize tumor heterogeneity
in this particular example we wanted to
look at the expression of pdl1
mrna in non-cancer tumors as you can see
here we have
compared expression of pdl1 in four
different lung cancer tumors
and the expression of pdl one varies
dramatically
based on the different samples
as you can see the expression of pdl one
is significantly higher
in sample 2 b2 compared to 2c4
now this highlights the heterogeneous
expression
of pdl1 uh between different tumor types
interestingly pdl1 not only shows
inter-tumor heterogeneity
but it also shows intra-tumor
heterogeneous expression
by which i mean the expression of pdl-1
varies based on the region within the
same tumor
where you can see in the box highlighted
on the top of the image
the expression of pdl one is
significantly higher
compared to the box that is highlighted
in the bottom part of the image
so this shows that different cancer
cells within the same tumors
can have different degree of your target
gene expression
and these subtle differences in
expression can be important
when you are studying markers like pdl
pdl1 pd1
which are important immunotherapy
targets
here's an example of how the script of
researchers use rna score
to study the heterogeneity of vent
ligand expression
in this pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma
organoid library
they wanted to study the expression of
wind ligands
and establish the expression of these
ligands the difference
the differential expression of these
ligands between normal pancreas
compared to a wind positive
pdac tumor and even negative pgac tumor
and as you can see the expression of
when time a
winston and went to b varies
between different tissue types where the
expression is highest
in the which positive are pdac tumors
whereas the expression is very low to
negligible
in the normal pancreas
next i will talk about the use of rna
scope in characterizing immune cells
and soluble factors like cytokines
chemokines and so on
a lot of the times researchers are
interested in visualizing rna and
protein simultaneously
on the same section of the tissue and
with the response technology we allow
for a workflow
where you can perform your ish essay
followed by which you can perform
our inc or raf for your protein target
and this becomes especially significant
in immunology
where you would want to detect specific
immune cell types
using your antibody of interest and then
visualize gene expression within these
immune cells
using rna's whole age and here's a great
example for the same
where in the cervical cancer tumor we
used the cd3 antibody
to mark all the t cells seen in green
and then used rna scope to visualize
expression of pdl1
pd1 and interferon gamma within these
cells
now if you can see the cell marked in
the yellow arrow
that's a t cell expressing high levels
of interferon gap
and using this joint workflow we're able
to identify
uh the active immune cells within a
tumor microenvironment
next is an example of how researchers
have used this dual hidec workflow
to advance their oncology research in
this paper published in nature last year
this group of researchers wanted to
study the cellular factor lift
and its effect on a pancreatic cancer
group
as you can see using the duplex assay
they were able to show
that the lift is expressed by the
stellate cells in the stroma
and they exert their effect in a in a
paraffin action
on the tumor cells marked by keratin 19.
they show this again by using our
multiplex assay and multiple marker and
visualize multiple markers
simultaneously
here they have used the dualish if
workflow where they've used the keratin
19 antibody to mark the tumor cells
and then visualize the lift factor in
combination with cd45
and the stroke they also show that this
lift
is significant in promoting cancer
growth by showing that the level of this
lift
was higher in cancer patients in the
blood of cancer patients compared to
normal patients
normal or normal individuals they also
show
a strong association of live mrna
with decreased disease free survival in
the patients
so using ironiscope they were able to
visualize
the specific stroman expression of this
left factor
and understand how this influences
growth of pancreatic cancer
next i'm going to show you an example of
how using our base scope assay
you can identify specific cdr3 regions
on tcr's using our base scope as
a you can design specific pro
against the hyper variable cdr3 regions
on tcrs
which can help you identify specific sub
populations of t
cells now this is a great example
uh from a paper that was published by dr
barco's lab at
vanderbilt where they were treating a
patient with antiped1 therapy
and this patient started showing adverse
events due to this therapy
uh causing encephalitis in this patient
which was
ultimately saturn now this group wanted
to study
what induced the sense of light is and
identify the cell population
responsible for reducing the sense of
blindness
so when they performed tcr sequencing
they identified a sequence that was
predominantly expressed
in this encephalitis tissue they
designed a specific base coprobe against
the sequence
and identify or localized this tcr
within the encephalitis tissue
interestingly
using base co they were able to
co-localize this tcr
with a cd4 population of t cells and not
cd8 population of t
cells indicating that the immune
population inducing encephalitis
was a cd4 population theta later
they were able to identify that indeed
it was a cd4 positive memory keysight
population
that was responsible for reducing this
encephalitis in the patient
so using our base scope assay and
specific probes against tcr
they were able to visualize this
population and co-localize
with the right immune cell marker to
identify the exact population of t cells
in this other example this group of
researchers was studying the gamma
dietary cell population
and the changes in this t-cell
population as it relates to
potentiating tumor growth they were able
to show
that with age there was a change in the
gamma-ray cell population
and there was an increase in il-7
expressing cells
or with age so if you compare here
mice that were older showed higher
expression
of il7 expressing gamma delta t cells
compared to younger mice and this was
directly associated with
increased tuber growth in this animal
model
next i want to show you an example of
how early scope has been used
to detect engineered immune t cells uh
by using uh example
of our collaboration with uber bio
bluebird bio was developing a
uh car t cell therapy against the bcna
artisan and the rod one antigen
and they wanted to use early school to
study the efficacy
uh and the safety of these car t cells
by designing a specific role against the
three prime utr
of the car vector they were able to
visualize these
rt cells within the animal model
similarly they designed uh rd scope
probes for organizing
to visualize the engagement of these car
t-cells
as you can see in this particular image
uh
this particular animal was given the
anti-vcme cardi
therapy and in this particular zero
graph of the animal model you can
visualize the bcme antiquation and you
can also visualize the car t cells
here in red now because the antigen was
present
you can see that these cartis has
engaged with these uh antigen
presenting um tumor cells and you can
see high expression of grand design b
telling you that these cartilage cells
are highly specific for bcma
and show an engagement in presence of
the antigen
on the other hand the anti-war one
cardiotherapy
was not as
safe as you can see here in this mouse
long tissue
there is some basal level of expression
of raw one
and as a result of this these car t
cells
were engaging with these cells in the
lung and causing toxic effects
now when they try to use inc to
understand
why they were seeing lung toxicity they
were not able to see any rare one
expression
but by using the rna scope assay they
could see
that there was some basal expression of
raw one which was causing these cardi
cells
to engage and give a on target but of
tumor effect
as a result this therapy is not safe and
was causing significant toxicity
next i want to show you an example of
how rna scope has been applied
to spatially back and validate single
cell rna sequencing data
in tumors now single-cell rna sequencing
has emerged as a valuable technique
to analyze uh complex tissues and assess
the heterogeneity
within these tissues but what you do not
get out of this technology is the
spatial and morphological resolution
and as a result it is a very popular
workflow to perform signal re sequencing
and then validate some of the key
targets using
rna scope in this particular example
this group of researchers from mit and
harvard used iron scope to validate
certain key targets
in glioblastoma using single cell rna
sequencing
they were able to identify four
different cellular states
in which video blastoma cells exist and
identify specific markers associated
with each of these
cellular states when they visualized
these markers
using rna scope they saw that some cells
expressed
markers for more than one cellular state
indicating that certain glioblastoma
cells can exist in a hybrid state
showing phenotypes of more than one
cellular state
and this is this was important discovery
to understand how these glioblastoma
cells
behave in situ and potentially develop a
um successful therapy against this
technique cancer
so using iroscope they were able to
validate and also
visualize these hybrid hybrid states of
tumors tumor cells
within this glioblastoma next i want to
talk to you about
the application of rna scope in
visualizing splice variants
that are implicated in certain cancers
here's an example of uh how researchers
used the payscope assay to visualize
delta 16 hold up slice variant
in patient samples and stratify patients
for herceptin therapy
tumors that have the delta 16 her2
splice variant
are susceptible to herceptin so using
the pascope assay they designed
probes that would specifically identify
the delta 16 splice variant
and differentiate that from the y-type
co2 receptor
if you can see in the panel uh on the
left-hand side
you have the curve to ilc which is not
able to differentiate between the y-side
and the delta-16 variant whereas the rn
scope assay was able to differentiate
between the delta 16 splice variant
and the y type as a result they were
able to stratify
patients based on the rna scope or the
base scope signal
from this analysis one of the final
applications that i want to talk to you
about
the is the detection of long non-coding
rnas
using rna scope
here's an example of how researchers use
the rna scope assay
to visualize a large nuclear variant
of look at one long non-coding argument
as you can see in this panel on the top
uh the expression of the nuclear variant
of
look at one long non-coding rna was
upregulated
under hypoxic conditions um compared to
uh normoxia and this phenotype
uh promoted an aggressive
growth of lung adrenal carcinomas in
this animal model
in this second example these researchers
wanted to study
the expression of this long-haunted rna
in
the brain cancer frame the breast cancer
brain metastasis
as you can see here they compared the
expression of this long non-coding rna
between breast cancer that had green
metastasis
compared to breast cancer that was
negative for brain metastasis
and the expression of this long
non-coding rna is significantly
upregulated
in the sample that had complained
metastasis indicating that
this particular non-coding rna is a
prognostic marker
for indicating progression to brain
metastasis
next is an example of a few long long
non-coding rnas
that we studied internally to show
that our technology is able to not only
detect real non-coding rnas
but differentiate between the
subcellular expression
of these non-coding ions for example
you can see that the mallet one long
non-coding rna
showed a nuclear expression whereas
the gap 5 down on coding rna present
in breast cancer tumors showed both
nuclear and cytoplasmic expression
so using this technology you can detect
your long encoding ironing of interest
and also study their sub-cellular
localization
which can provide significant clues as
to the function
of the long-run kodi rna and their
prognostic value
we have then applied across various
research and application areas
and the adoption of our technology is
clear from this graph
which indicates the number of
publications that we have using rna
scope
currently we have over 2700 publications
and they have been uh published in
different research areas with cancer
neuroscience
and infectious disease being our top
three
next i want to talk to you about a very
interesting collaboration
of acd bio technique with nano string
to combine our rna scope and geo xtsp
technologies
here is an image of the workflow wherein
you can use rna scope as a molecular
guide
to characterize specific regions in the
tissue
to perform digital spatial profiling
we wanted to show the application of
this joint workflow
using a specific example so we decided
to study the immune cell infiltration
uh within lung cancer tumor
microenvironment so for that the step
one was to identify markers to perform
rna scope
on the lung cancer tissue
cd3 and cd19 are the most common immune
cell markers
uh that would detect t cells in b cells
respectively
we use that as molecular guides uh to
perform rna scope
as you can see here the expression of
the cd19 and cd3 markers
uh was very dramatically based on
different regions
within this non-small cell lung cancer
tissue
and we decided to profile 25 different
regions of interest with variable cd19
and cd3 expression
using the geomets dsp so the next step
was to profile the selected otherwise
using geomix tsp
once we did that we were able to
identify a set of genes
that were differentially expressed
between the cd19 rich roi
versus the cd3 rich roi
and the final step was to select
some key targets analyzed from the
geomets analysis
and visualize them using rna's home on a
serial section
so for that we decided to pick two rois
roi6
that was rich in cd19 and roi 11
that was rich in cd3
we decided to compare the expression of
cd8 interferon gamma
cxcl9 and ccl5 between these two rois
as you can see here the expression of
all these four targets
was dramatically high in the roi 11
compared to roi 6.
now roi 11 is the cd 3 ridge or the t
cell rich region and as a result
uh we would expect the expression of
these targets to be high in this roi
since most of them are t cell markers
interestingly the expression pattern
seen here using rna scope
was concordant with what we observed
with the geomets dsp
analysis again showing that these two
assays are
coherent and show similar expression
analysis audioscope also allows for
single cell and single molecule
detection
as observed here in these individual
channel paths
by summary using the rd scope we were
able to identify specific regions of
interest
using geomix tsp we were able to profile
these
regions of interest and then finally
after identifying key targets
we could perform rna scope again to
visualize these targets using
e-morphological
and single cell resolution using rna
scope
so with these two technologies we really
wanted to combine the unique
capabilities of
the jomex csp in providing high flex
profiling
of target genes and then use iron scope
to provide that single cell
resolution with morphological context
so with this we hope to provide a
complete solution for gene expression
analysis
of heterogeneous tumors or using single
cell resolution
next i just want to take a couple of
minutes to uh
show how acd biotechne is supporting the
advancement of over 19 research
uh we have covert 19 specific probes
um for rna scope analysis we also have
probes specific for the receptor and
protease expression
you can study the immune response by
visualizing
cytokine and immune cell expression and
finally we have marker probes
to visualize the pathological and
physiological markers
uh to study the homeostasis of our
infected tissues
uh we also have a lot of material
available online
for people who are interested in knowing
more about our joint workflow
or we will also be presenting a joint
poster at the upcoming asdr meaning in
shoe
with that i would just like to highlight
that in this current environment
a lot of us cannot go back to labs to
continue our research
but at uh acde biotechnique we have a
dedicated group of researchers
that are working on uh performing your
experiments for you
and providing the results and data uh
we call them pharma asset services for
our biopharma customers
and academic asset services for our
academic customer
customers so for more information please
reach out to me or
reach out to our technical support and
find out about this
thank you
thank you that was a really wonderful
presentation we have a number of
questions for you now
the first one is how can you be sure
that one dot
is equivalent to one transcript
so that is a very interesting question
in our technology paper that was
published in 2012
we have shown how one god correlates to
a single transcript of rna
so uh please go over that particular
manuscript
and come back to us with any more
questions that you might have
anushka another question for you here
can the rna scope
geomics workflow be performed only using
the leica automated platform
the arduous scope jomex uh joint
workflow
can be performed both in a manual as
well as an automated platform
uh the automated platform uh is
performed on nika
uh but we do have a joint workflow that
is available
for manual assays as well so you can
perform it both
using manual as well as auto automated
assets
and finally anushka your third question
is is co-detection of rna and protein
using rna scope and ihc possible on
fresh frozen samples
the dual ish ic workflow or core
detection
of rna of the protein can be performed
on ffpe as well as fresh frozen tissues
so yes it can be performed on
fresh frozen samples as well
using the rna scope assay or oncology
research
you can understand the complex patient
relationships
among different cell types within the tn
uh you can profile immune cells and
checkpoint markers
uh that are important therapeutic
targets
uh and you can characterize the new cell
types and subtypes
and study their activation states by
visualizing
soluble factors like cytokines and
chemokines
using our technology